all right welcome everybody it is a very
weird day but it is Election Day March
17th we have three primary scheduled two
before of course but Ohio deciding to
postpone their primary we have Florida
Illinois and Arizona we have early
results from Florida where with sixty
point seven percent reporting Joe Biden
is up by 38 that is a sorry hold on this
that doesn't look right there we go and
that is a major lead and very very
quickly and very quickly looking good
for Joe Biden there of course and Biden
widely expected to win all states today
but in particular Florida was going to
be from the beginning we knew Florida
would be very very good for Joseph R
Biden Jr a little more zoom I think
gives us about about the angle that we
are looking for let's see what else we
have here nothing else okay very good
um let's click in and look at some
Florida details as they continue to come
in so far a sixty point seven for Joseph
R Biden Jr twenty two point six for
Bernie others sixteen point two and
Tulsi with zero point five percent
that's with about sixty percent
reporting Donald Trump easily winning
the Republican primary essentially
meaningless at this point in time and we
have I mean listen I don't know that
this information really means very much
to us it's just a very very big victory
for Joe Biden and we will continue to
track I don't know if this has been
called but it is essentially over
waiting on Illinois results which should
start to come in very very soon and
we'll continue to track all of this
stuff quick reminder going into tonight
Joe Biden leading by 153 Delegates Joe
Biden 898 Bernie Sanders 7:45 and you
know that but one of the stories today
as I tweeted earlier there is a big
contradiction between number one don't
congregate in groups larger than 10 and
number two have millions of people vote
in primary elections at
schools and senior centers will Bernie
Sanders dropout after today I don't know
I mean I started I was getting messages
from people saying Bernie texted me
about making sure I vote in New York you
know which is later on in the primary
process you know everybody does that
everybody does that and I I don't know I
I think that by the end of tonight there
will be not so for now Joe Biden has had
a hypothetical path to victory that
looked difficult for birdie to overtake
I think after tonight Bernie's even
hypothetical chances will essentially be
gone so we will see we will be here for
the results I want to hear from you
what's on your mind in these weird times
let me know if you're watching on
youtube you can send a super chat and
it'll show up on the bottom left where
it says no super chats which is very sad
these first moments of streams always
very sad before any super chats come in
if you're watching on Twitch you can
include a message with a twitch Prime
subscription or regular trips twitch
subscription spider-man 2099 89 for
example signed up via twitch and if you
are watching on Facebook we now are part
of the Facebook direct subscription
program which you can also feel very
much free to take advantage of we now
are starting to get some Illinois
numbers those are starting to come in
and we will see okay so Florida has been
called for Joseph R Biden Jr let's see
if we have any update to the delegate
numbers I'm not sure if that's updating
in real-time if it is there hasn't been
any move yet Joe Biden wins Florida in a
blowout over Bernie Sanders and we now
have Illinois in in play polls are
closed and we will see as the numbers
start to come in maybe zoom this one I
actually I think it's okay so there it
is we'll start to see these numbers come
in very very soon I want to hear from
people is this the end for Bernie
Sanders what will be the impact of
coronavirus you know I was thinking very
often there's a Jewish proverb I could I
could tell here but I don't think I can
make it I can make it a more neutral
very often there's a Hitler's a Calvin
and Hobbes comic I know every Calvin and
Hobbes comic grew up reading Calvin and
Hobbes and then that comic Calvin is
complaining to his dad about how cold it
is in the house
Calvin wants the temperature warmer and
his dad says I have an idea go stand
outside in your t-shirt for a second in
the middle of winter and Calvin does it
and then he says what's the point of
this and his dad says as soon as you
come back in the house it's gonna feel
very very warm to you I think that that
applies to what we are now experiencing
I now and very quickly of the mindset
that once things go back to being normal
what up until a few weeks ago was just
everyday we had gotten completely
desensitized to it I think it's gonna
feel pretty good and that's why we need
to band together we need to do the right
thing we need to stay away from public
places I'm doing it everybody that I
know is doing it I know a lot of
Republicans in Florida aren't doing it
and they're going to the to the beach
and doing stuff that really is not going
to help but we are fighting we are
fighting the virus and we are fighting
disinformation and in the meantime
they're trying to run a primary so
listen this is all very weird right I
mean on the one hand you're not supposed
to be in groups larger than 10 and we
have primaries but one is delayed and
you know we did these are the elections
these elections anybody thinking these
elections aren't going to count these
are going account we heard about long
waits and we heard about people
congregating too closely this is what
we've got and Florida has been called
for Joe Biden I wouldn't be surprised if
Illinois and Arizona very quickly get
called for Joe Biden as well although we
are waiting for waiting for the first
numbers I'm not gonna do you know my
full analysis of why Bernie lost I've
done it
i-i've said before a lot of the right
ideas not a great candidate a lot of
toxic people around him the electorate
is not nearly as progressive as me for
example these are just realities and
there's going to be more than enough
time in sort of doing the postmortem
the midst of very very acutely trying
times not just for the United States but
for the world let me see what this first
super chat is as they come in they will
kind of show up towards the bottom of
the screen
Blizz ZX says hey David I live in
Florida and Malin voted for Bernie I
live near a polling station and to my
surprise I saw three Bernie sighs signs
and no Biden signs all right very good
interesting interesting anecdote there
let me say thank you to a few folks who
are kicking off the night with new
memberships at join pakman.com Ashley
balk or ba has signed up and is new
member number one tonight and Beverly
Garfinkel Beverly Thank You Beverly is
not only a new david pakman show member
but beverly has also just made a $10 a
month pledge via via patreon which I of
course very very much appreciate and
encourage you to support the stream by
grabbing a membership at join pakman.com
as we together start to see results come
in not surprisingly Tulsi is losing to
people that long dropped long ago
dropped out and a lot of people have
been emailing me saying David can you
can you elaborate on what you think
Tulsi Zen game is I have no idea and I
don't care I mean she she's going on Fox
she's talking about how everybody's
silencing her the voters of silenced her
nobody voted for more people voted for
Michael Bloomberg in Florida who's not
even running then for then for Tulsi so
it's I just don't care I don't think
it's worth discussing super chats
continue to come in Lee Douglas says my
husband that I love your show you're
getting us through this difficult time
we are members who listen daily and
watch your live stream stay safe Thank
You Lee shoutout to you and your husband
I very much appreciate your support I
also want to say thanks to Michael Scott
Matthews who has grabbed a youtube
subscription as we patiently wait for
the first numbers out of Illinois
Florida already called for Joe Biden
with a big lead and in fact let's
compare it to
let's compare it to the polls in Florida
let's take a look
Florida Democratic primary Biden was
plus 39 in the polling and so far Biden
is plus 39 that's fascinating plus 39 so
so the polling absolutely spot-on so far
so far although it is of course still
very early
hey Zachary Monroe great to see you Zach
Zach a longtime supporter of the streams
Zach says have you heard about the ernit
bill removing end-to-end encryption I
have not I have not Republicans trying
to pass the bill during this time when
all focus is on the virus I posted a
discussion on your reddit I'll check
that out oh and I see only a little bit
of it as visible here there we go
there's X message I don't know anything
about that but I will certainly check
that out if you're just joining us at
the start of the night it was a hundred
and fifty three delegate lead for Joseph
R Biden Jr that information has for has
been updated it has been updated and the
lead has now expanded to 24 and 53 77
177 is that right as my math right 177
delegate lead for Joe for Joseph R Biden
Jr over Bernie Sanders remember I care
about data and math so I will continue
to try to bring you the the latest
numbers there but looks like a hundred
and seventy seven vote more delicate
margin now for Joe Biden and listen I I
know a lot of people have been are
saying to me David why you seemed why
don't you're not you're not confused
about this no I'm not I mean I the this
is I after Super Tuesday listen before
Super Tuesday I believed it was about
85% over for Bernie after Super Tuesday
I believe that was about 92% over for
Bernie after the March 10 primaries I
believed it was 99% over for Bernie and
now I believe it is over for Bernie 99.9
right call it what you want and this is
a reality that we have to deal with at
this point in time the question now of
course is what happens in the general I
actually believe and this my audience is
kind of split about this over the last
24
hours and I know that after 38 months 24
hours seems meaningless over the last 24
hours
Donald Trump instead of being 100%
unhinged has only been 90 percent
unhinged and 10 percent presidential he
actually is taking this seriously he's
lying uncontrollably diarrhea of the
mouth but the truth is if in the next
three to four months
the virus situation starts turning
around and Donald Trump maintains a
marginally more sober tone I think Trump
gets himself reelected whether it's
Bernie or Biden that that's my my deep
sincere genuine feeling the we are in an
unprecedented situation and Donald Trump
acting marginally more like a normal
person I believe may lead to his victory
in November if and that's a big if
coronavirus starts to cool off by then
and of course the corona of virus
numbers coronavirus numbers now are
extremely extremely disturbing and it's
getting very very bad and you know Trump
still calling it the Chinese virus on
Twitter and doing absolutely bogus
cuckoo stuff but again I'm trying to
think about this my opinion is
irrelevant I'm in this stuff every day I
have to work to think about for the
average of America how will they see
this and I think it's gonna be very very
difficult for whoever is the Democratic
nominee if coronavirus does get under
control and you know when Trump says
eventually the recovery is going to be
phenomenal that's true the question is
is the recovery in three months six
months one year three years or five
years if you look at what happened in
Japan they had decades decades before
they got back to where they were after
the the downturn of the 80s so again I
it's possible this is the end of the
planet and the human species I don't
believe that if it is it's not gonna
matter whether I have cash gold or
stocks right I'm operating under the
belief that eventually there will be a
recovery I'm continuing to buy stock
and I believe the recovery will
eventually be really good if it happens
from August to November Trump wins that
that's just a reality that history tells
us and it's I know a lot of people don't
like that but I'm not here to blow smoke
up anybody's ass okay you want that find
other channels I don't know I couldn't
recommend any but maybe there are some
that do a lot of blowing smoke
Linda freeters is joining us tonight as
new member number three thanks Linda we
do have a membership promo where you
save 66% and you can sign up at join
pakman.com coupon code is twenty-twenty
now you save 66% the blue bar fills up I
say your name and everybody just
absolutely loves it okay other super
chats coming in Zachary Monroe oh okay
he already we already did that Rick
Hammond says sadly it looks like Biden
but let's face it a potted plant would
be better than Trump vote blue in
November stay safe people if you are
just joining us Florida was instant
almost instantly called for Joseph R
Biden Jr a massive massive victory and
okay as you can see 61 percent so far
for Joe Biden in Florida we don't yet
have any numbers out of Illinois but we
are standing by for them the delegate
count has been updated the lead has
swelled to 205 delegates for Bernie and
my indication was if the lead is more
than 200 by the end of the night it's
over and probably probably if that's the
case Bernie should drop out tomorrow
there's no need to keep people going out
to primaries we're trying to distance
people the the math isn't going to be
there for him if the if the lead remains
more than 200 if anybody wants to make
not an emotional case but a mathematical
case for doing otherwise I am glad to
hear it won the lead has now swelled to
one to 41 I believe it is I'm sorry
245 26 and 19 yeah 245 the lead is now
245 and that the numbers are getting
pretty overwhelming looking at the
popular vote my prediction was that by
the end of the night Bernie Sanders may
be down more than two million votes to
Biden and indeed we have crossed that
threshold ladies and gentlemen Joseph R
Biden Jr now ahead of Bernie by more
than two million votes in this primary
so far so those numbers are accumulating
very very quickly and let's see if we
look at the county numbers is there any
cap T that Bernie Sanders won no right
am I my correctly seeing that there is
not a single County that Bernie Sanders
won I mean okay Okaloosa we have no
results yet homes in Washington and Bay
and Jackson we have no results but it
looks like every single County in
Florida has gone to Joseph R Biden Jr
which is which is incredible it is
incredible
and even as people are pointing out
heavy University counties Bernie didn't
win and that's that's where we are right
now ladies and gentlemen that is where
we are right now and we will stand by
for vote totals coming in from from
Illinois momentarily and the delegates
spread is getting very very big again my
prediction is it we may see Biden Bernie
rather wrap relatively soon is there
another Street I was hoping to get the
Washington Post live stream live YouTube
because they actually go to rallies and
such but I don't know that they are
actually streaming live if anybody else
has another non risky stream that we
could pick up I would be glad to do it
one that will carry the speeches
election results and then I will sort by
live I'm just taking a look here Wow if
you right now if you will at least for
me if I search for election results on
YouTube and put live this stream is the
one that comes up first and that's
thanks to people liking and subscribing
so please make sure if you're watching
on YouTube you hit like and subscribe
we have the PBS stream there's a there's
an ABC stream which could be could be a
little dicey let's just take a look at
what's happening there just to get a
sense of it huh okay well I guess
they're doing something we'll we'll keep
an eye on different different possible
streams there and see see what is going
on okay other super chats coming and I
do want to hear from you if you're
watching on twitch you can include a
message question with your a twitch
prime or twitch subscription it looks
like we just got a little bit of early
data from Illinois so far Joseph R Biden
Jr looks like he's plus 36 in Illinois
but it is literally 18,000 votes that is
all 0.01 percent reporting still plenty
of time for those numbers to change Greg
Bell says David I appreciate what you do
keep fighting the good fight brother
thank you I appreciate your support I
really appreciate that you are here Bowl
rot sends a $20 super chat the biggest
of the evening with no message just just
sending 20 bucks thank you very much I
appreciate that very very much and we
are now starting we are now starting to
get a little bit more of that Illinois
data coming in and we have what is this
Illinois we have now five okay five out
of 10,000 precincts reporting Joseph R
Biden Jr has gone up plus 37 now as a
reminder Illinois let's take a look at
where Illinois was what was the polling
there Biden was plus 29 in Illinois will
see if and how he performs relative to
those numbers and again if we get to 2%
with this margin and the exit polls show
this it'll be called for Biden close to
instantly close to instantly let's see
so a B News ABC News is covering they're
talking a lot about kovat which we're
talking about a lot and then we have the
Illinois numbers coming in here as well
okay
this is not an alias says via super chat
David how boned are we really we're
we're pretty boned when it comes to
coronavirus and you know people in
florida are going around partying and
going to beaches so it's it's ugly
farmer kip says stay safe out there
everyone yes indeed very much and as you
can see in Florida Michael Bloomberg
with a very risk listen if it weren't
for Michael Bloomberg getting 9% in
Florida you might see Bernie below the
viability threshold potentially
potentially it would be a fight it would
be a fight for viability for Bernie if
you did not have if you did not have
Michael Bloomberg with nine that that
would put Bernie potentially at thirteen
or fourteen in a sense Bernie is
probably gonna pull some delegates
because Michael Bloomberg is is in there
which is which is incredible it's
incredible quite frankly Alpha says
David better VP candidate clos Bashar or
Warren I'm thinking about that I don't
want to make a definitive statement yet
I I've been so obviously Warren is more
my politics in terms of political
alignment than Amy Klobuchar but in
terms of in terms of thinking about who
would who would likely bring in more
votes I'm thinking of I don't know the
answer probably would be different in
different parts of the country
Diana Bridget says can't work self
isolated the David Pakman show is a
great comfort it listen we're also you
know we've moved that we've
decentralized production we're working
out of our homes we are everything has
been shaken up for us as well and just
having the sort of normalcy of
continuing to do the show and do streams
it's it's good for us as well mr. Dilk
ington
sixteen has subscribed with twitch prime
and I I appreciate that
very very much we do have a new member
coupon 2020 now where you save sixty-six
percent when you sign up at join
pakman.com and then the blue bar fills
up hopefully all the way to 25 and I
thank you I say your name so you can
sign up at join pakman.com I do want to
thank thar degraded whoo
has subscribed with twitch prime Florida
has been called if you're just joining
us we are interested now in Illinois
where we have very very small numbers
reporting still only point zero five
percent of precincts and that's what
we're keeping an eye on at this point
because that would be that that's going
to be the next one that likely we will
we will get a result from again now
we're just little tiny bits and pieces
going to 0.08% reporting that lead for
Biden is still big of course widely
expected to win based on the polling but
you just never know this is why you vote
this is why you vote and very very
important to do so angle or Angelle says
I live in Tampa Florida the local news
stations lean trumpian and two weeks ago
everyone was saying no big deal same as
the flu and even my girlfriend's sister
said I have a life to live and was on
the beach well that that is going to
lead to more coronavirus sadly I wish it
were different but that is that is the
way it's going let's look at the
official case numbers which of course
are completely worthless to us we are
almost at 200,000 cases likely tomorrow
we will hit eight thousand deaths
looking at the number of active cases
there are now almost 100,000 people
known to be active these numbers are
almost meaningless quite frankly when
you actually think about sorry about
that when you actually look at how few
how few tests we are doing the u.s. now
officially and and look we're testing
more and the numbers are absolutely
exploding we likely have depending on
the estimates if this is like super
super rough math but Justin just to do
it because we have the time here I
understand that this doesn't account for
the fact that a lot of these cases are
open if we believe that this in the end
will be roughly a 1% mortality rate
we've had a hundred and nine deaths that
implies that we have
10900 active cases in reality the the
death rate may end up being more like
0.7 that would imply that we have more
like 15,000 cases but once we found out
that all of these NBA players who are
asymptomatic have it we could be talking
about 500,000 active cases in the US we
could be talking about him we don't have
any idea
we simply have absolutely no idea about
the actual number of active cases
because we aren't testing only places
like you know South Korea is testing
extensively and a few other places are
doing more tests but we just do not know
we do not know the only thing you can do
is uh stay home yeah that's really all
you can do guys I know that this math
doesn't tell us we multiply we don't
know what the multiple is but the point
is we are so far off we are so far off
that it's almost meaningless to say oh
we went from you know 4,800 to 6,400
cases we likely have tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands or more cases
at this point we could have listened the
number of people I know who had myself
included I believe I may have had it if
these cases are truly asymptomatic back
in December January I know a bunch of
people who had tightness in their chest
and a cough and they had workups they
were checked for flu they never had a
fever they got an x-ray it was normal
etc etc that could have been an
asymptomatic mild case I had a cough for
about eight days very very light cough
and a headache could that have been an
asymptomatic mild case I don't know and
again the test we have now is a test for
the pathogen not for antibodies so we
have no way right now of actually
testing and to figure out who has had it
because the belief is that if you've
recovered you are immune for at minimum
a year possibly for life it depends on
virus mutation and a whole bunch of
other things and I may never know the
full truth of who has had it okay let's
see
Gustavo Morales says an opinion on the
new President of Argentina I I don't
like him it's not I'm not a I'm not a
I'm not a Kirsten at ista so I don't
like the guy but he's shutting stuff
down and that's good
Arthur chouette C says don't you think
Trump will bankrupt the country yet
Trump all of a sudden is doing all the
things we supposedly couldn't ever
afford when it was Democrats proposing
that that we in-state some of these
social insurance programs no I don't
think Trump's going to bankrupt the
country I don't
Charmander Sharma Andrew says YouTube is
an echo chamber Bernie isn't popular in
real life well not as pop listen Bernie
is not as popular as his own rallies
Reddit and Twitter suggests we learned
that very quickly there's no denying
that that's an empirical fact when you
look at the fact that Joe Biden is
winning by more than two million votes
in this thing it's very very hard to to
deny that reality
we're waiting on continued election
results the the delegate counts have
been updated and Joe Biden is now
winning by 250 to 56
is that it yes to 56 and that's a big
that's that's starting to become a
prohibitive delegate lead for sure
Illinois has now been called for Joseph
R Biden Jr despite the fact that only 1%
is reporting the exit polls are so
skewed that Joe Biden has won Illinois
and that is that's it for Illinois
Florida has also been called and now we
are just waiting on Arizona Arizona
which will close in about 90 minutes
Charlie says with a $50 Super chat Thank
You charlie thanks for the great
coverage you provide you're making a
difference keep it up vote blue PS are
you sponsored by hyal microphone stands
I'm not know I know but yeah soompi
someone said I should actually black
that out with a sharpie maybe y'all know
I won't do it right now
but maybe if we get to 25 members
I will I will black out huh of course it
has nothing to do with Heil Hitler I
think it's just some dude like John Heil
who makes Mike stands in the US and he's
a good guy and he makes beautiful we've
been looking at his mic stands very
strongly for a long time and they are
beautiful beautiful mic stands the best
I would even say the channel our
president
Alex D says the Dems really want to give
Trump four more years by ignoring all of
Biden's flaws I'm gonna laugh at their
misery when Trump is reelected you may
well be laughing I may well be there
with you my friend laughing in order to
avoid crying of course remember that if
you're just joining us on Twitch
Facebook live or YouTube the big news so
far Ohio postponing their primary they
are not voting today that leaves us
Florida Illinois and Arizona Florida has
been called for Joseph R Biden Jr who is
currently +39 putting him a couple
hundred depending on which tracker you
look at Biden is about two hundred and
fifty delegates ahead big win in Florida
for Joe Biden but predictable we knew
this was going to happen two weeks ago a
lot of people yelled at me they said no
way David Illinois has also been called
for Joseph R Biden Jr it is such a big
spread that it has been called with two
percent reporting Biden is plus thirty
five in Illinois and now we are just
waiting on Arizona let's take a look at
what the polling was in Arizona and see
what we might expect Arizona of
Democratic primary Biden plus 18 so it
by all likelihood if the results mirror
the polls even remotely we would expect
that Bernie Sanders would be the closest
in Arizona and we will not know the
details there until 10:00 p.m. Eastern
Time just about 90 minutes away in the
meantime I want to hear from you if
you're watching on YouTube consider
sending a super chat super chats will
show up in the bottom left of the chat
window there over there send them in I
will read them I will answer and tell
you what is on my on my mind about what
you are saying
the two topics today are coronavirus and
the primaries and they are related as I
tweeted earlier there is a big
contradiction between don't congregate
in groups larger than 10 and having
millions of people vote in primary
elections at schools and senior centers
this is what it is these are today is
when we are getting results from some of
these states and it doesn't appear to
make a whole lot of sense from a public
health perspective but alas that is that
is what we have Jackson Jackson to me
Stowe says I thought all the Boomers
would stay home because of Corona bad
news for Bernie listen you know there's
always these expectations that are
totally out of whack I had a bunch of
people saying David that one-on-one
debate on Sunday night Biden is gonna go
full dementia he's gonna be incoherent
and Bernie will take over and it's like
guys no that was never likely to happen
and it didn't happen and in fact the
polls didn't move at all after that
Sunday night debate last week and this
week people are saying David Corona will
help will hold old people back from
voting and it will be great for Bernie
he'll overperform not happening you know
and and sometimes I feel bad because
people have such unrealistic
expectations about what what might
happen that it's just you know I don't
know I I try to be a little bit more
more realistic it was unlikely that that
was ever going to happen because here in
Canada trying to validate not creating
this rumor Trump was tested for kovat 19
you or anyone aware trying to validate
not Trump said that he was tested on
Friday night and that he tested negative
it's weird in fact let's find let me see
Trump test negative let me see if I can
find the video the video made it sound
like he didn't really know what the test
even is let's see if we can find that
video
maybe if I search for Trump medical test
he had this bizarre answer it's
struggling to find the video
his trumpet said frump man what should i
search for trump coronavirus test nope
not there was this I think this was that
this has silver it was doing crazy did
you do the tennis did you do the test so
very late on Friday night I did the test
yes he seems to react like she knows
he's lying but let's see maybe this is
it
and how would you rate your response to
this crisis I'd read it at 10
all right well anyway I'm having trouble
finding it but Trump he asked him what
did you think of the test and oh it is
not something I want to do every day I
can tell you that it's good job kiss in
the White House but it's a medical so
what I see when I watch that what I see
is Trump doesn't really know like what
do they do is that a blood test
are they having me pee in a cup are they
putting a thing in my nose it almost
seemed like he knew he didn't want to
say the wrong test format so he just
said that really weird thing I don't
know I really don't know the truth of it
I I'm just not sure could be could be
could be anything anything could be the
truth we live in a world where we just
don't know let me say thanks to David
billsborough David billsborough is new
member number four today at join
pakman.com David thank you for your
support I really do appreciate it we
have had a lot of streams there's almost
been daily streams lately they will
continue and I so appreciate folks
grabbing memberships for example using
that coupon code above my head 20 20 now
which saves you 66 percent okay
incredible TV says what is incredible
says what are your thoughts on day care
staying open thanks for streaming Dave
you're a voice of reason with all that
going on the hoarding at stores is
horrible please think about other folks
yeah I don't listen I have no opinion I
don't want to I just am going to repeat
what medical experts say the medical
experts seem to be looking at the day
care thing I'm gonna let them decide
about day cares Robert says everyone is
at home sounds like a perfect time to
start the children of the lie and mix
everyone's music together give the
people what they want I'm ready Adam
fresh designs says my Dixie wrecked I'm
so sorry to hear about your Dixie that's
too bad
Lauro imperial says was Bernie right to
denounce AIPAC I don't even know what he
said but I think it's all pretty pretty
irrelevant in the end techy Studios says
I understand Biden is not the best
choice I'd rather have a president who
can actually speak like an adult versus
a man-child the Bernie or bust movement
will be the reason Trump will win once
again
Zach Bushman says shame on all the
people hoping coronavirus turnout
reduction helps Bernie winning elections
through disenfranchisement is a
Republican tactic yeah listen here's my
view on this and this may be
controversial to some but it just seems
obvious to me I don't want anybody
getting coronavirus for political
benefit I don't for my side I don't want
anyone getting coronavirus because it'll
help remove Trump I don't want anybody
getting or dying from coronavirus period
that doesn't have to I'm not looking to
swin elections with people getting
coronavirus at strategic times that's
not the way I approach this stuff okay
and I don't know if people in my
audience disagree with that
Rock Lee says who is your favorite
president pre JFK Honest Abe you know
for me those questions are so fraught
and as someone who's in this stuff I see
all of these politicians you know
there's a lot of deifying of politicians
a lot of people deify you know the yang
Gang was deifying Andrew yang he's the
only person who can beat Trump Trump
supporters dfi Trump a lot of Bernie
supporters deify Bernie these are just
politicians you know and quite frankly I
I
I'm skeptical of the the fact that
someone chooses to become a politician
rather than doing other careers already
for me suggests that these are all folks
where we should say there's good things
and there's bad things and there's all
you know it's very hard for me to really
answer questions like my favorite
president because I just really don't
see it in those terms
Ariel Fernandez says wrong name wrong
name I don't know what that means
wrong name okay
techie Studios says mark my words it
will happen absolute nonsense says
dropped off a ballot in Phoenix Arizona
voted Bernie it was an empty church
nobody was at the polls sad this is
happening
Alex D says can Palestine survive four
more years of Trump um yeah I I think so
but I don't think any of us want to
survive another four years of Trump
Nathan halm says David this is
depressing worked hard for Bernie here
in Ohio it all seems to be for naught
what's your advice for saddened young
progressives saddened young progressives
are gonna need to really think long and
hard about whether they want another
four years of Trump and whether they
want Trump replacing Ruth Bader Ginsburg
okay that is going to be the question of
this year and of our time do you want
Trump replacing Ruth Bader Ginsberg if
you don't there's really only going to
be one step forward it's up to you
whether that makes sense or not
okay let's take a look at our updated
results if Florida has of course been
called for Joe Biden big margin of
victory
39% big big big margin of victory
Illinois has been called for Joe Biden
plus 31 point 7 in Illinois and the
updated delegate math oops sorry wrong
page now has Bernie Sanders nearly 300
electoral votes delegates I'm sorry this
is not the general election delegates
not electoral votes behind Joe Biden
looks like just 18 shy which would put
us at 288
I'm sorry 282 looks like 280
to delegate lead for Joe Biden my
thought was that if Bernie ends up more
than 200 down tonight Bernie should drop
out he doesn't really have a path to the
nomination if that's how far down he is
at the end of the night and it would
actually allow a lot of people not to go
out and expose themselves to coronavirus
in upcoming primaries if Bernie were to
drop out Bernie can't win guys I mean
listen we it's just the reality and we
want people to stay home and you coulda
said you wouldn't have to cancel any
primaries but you would just make it
irrelevant you know a few people would
mail in ballots absentee whatever Biden
it would just go to Biden I mean it
sucks but this is where we are and he
has no shot the numbers are overwhelming
and honestly these are the numbers that
we really need to get under control at
this point in time these are the numbers
that we can we we can set an inflection
point to go one way or a different way
Bernie's out you know Bernie's done at
this point and I think that we need to
do what the responsible thing given the
unique nature of the situation that we
are dealing with at this point in time
okay are there any other election
results streams that maybe we could use
to supplement because this ABC stream
quite frankly is very very lame
we have the PBS one we want to stay away
from any local news t Whitey's doing
results but we're kind of doing the same
thing they're doing globe elections I
don't know exactly what that is
Oh only five people are watching that
yeah I don't know maybe somebody can
recommend another stream that we could
that we could supplement with I do want
to remind you if you're just joining us
on YouTube please please please I'm
asking you this with all humility and in
with peace and love hit the like and
subscribe button right now when you
search YouTube for live streams with
election results we're at the top okay
keep us at the top by liking and
subscribing and we oh I my phone is
blowing up okay I'll see what's going on
and we will I think I think it will it
will
wonders for us I do appreciate folks who
are who are doing that let me say thank
you to or alia Ruiz who is new member
number five tonight thank you so much I
appreciate that you can grab a
membership at join pakman.com as we
watch the results come in let me say
thank you to Kindle lover for grabbing a
twist Prime subscription as well okay
other super chats that are coming in
Lauro Imperial says would you ever run
for office I would vote for you maybe I
don't know not not ruling anything out
but no office in the immediate that I
could see running for Caitlin M says
thank you for your coverage does it
freak you out that you or others could
be asymptomatic more testing needed
definitely yeah that's why I'm basically
just staying home I'm you know walking
outside when I have to go to grocery
stores I go and I stock up on some stuff
I have had to go to the post office once
actually went twice the first time there
was a huge line I just got the hell out
of there I did I nope right out of there
and walked out and I went back and had
to pick up a couple packages but I'm
that's I I could I could have had it I
could be I could be a symptomatically
transmitting it right now who knows who
knows and I don't want to take that
chance Mac says oh hold on uh where is
that I just missed it now there's math
max should Bernie have dissuaded voters
going out today I believe it's it's a
moot point
yeah but he was so far behind I don't
think it would have made a difference
whitest Asian has grabbed a twitch Prime
subscription with the message high and
Kindle lover has gifted to subscriptions
on Twitch which I very much appreciate a
Owens says TYT coverage of Biden being
senile what is your opinion haven't seen
it I mean I've been following the Biden
dementia stuff but I don't watch any
other channels that are like mine I get
enough of this stuff when I watch
YouTube I either watch concert videos by
the way did anybody see this is the
craziest thing I don't know who the hell
Harry Styles is like I know he's some
boy band kid right I don't
what is he from 5 seconds of summer or
10 minutes of winter or who the hell
knows where he's from
I said this you know sound of music I
have no clue what band he's from he was
on the Howard Stern Show did it cover
one direction there it is did a cover of
slept Peter Gabriel grape Gabriel's
sledgehammer fantastic fantastic
check it out on on YouTube excellent
excellent stuff anyway when I'm not
doing put you know the show I'm not
watching you know youtubers doing doing
doing videos political videos I'm
watching you know chess instruction and
very exciting stuff like like that
anyway okay
Trevor Martindale says who do you
believe will champion the progressive
movement after Bernie do you believe any
prominent progressives could break
Bernie's ceiling yes I do
Bernie's ceiling of 38 in great part was
because of Bernie not because of his
ideas
it was the rhetoric the people around
him Bernie himself it's not the the
ideas aren't the problem you we can we
can adjudicate we can argue over the
popularity of individual ideas the
feasibility of individual ideas but I
don't believe the ideas themselves were
actually the actually the problem base
baser says will this pandemic increase
the demand for humanist communities also
I work for high-end boutique microphone
company we can give you a massive
discount if you're interested in using
fans products I've never even heard of
that fans microphone is that what it is
I don't I'm not even finding that
googling it fans products high-end
boutique microphone company FAA email me
baser I'm always up listen I've had this
microphone for 10 years this EVR e20
this thing is a workhorse as many of you
know I've probably punched it a thousand
times during the show and it just
doesn't die so I'm perfectly happy with
it but I'm always up for considering new
equipment if it would be advantageous so
you contact me via my website jane woman
power says thanks David
remember kind viewers
like and subscribe very good advice
Junie McGraw says do you think the youth
turnout will cost Biden in November he
would be better than Trump but I don't
believe that would be enough to motivate
young people we'll have time to look at
those cross-sections for sure joke
rockin berg says can't cry if you don't
want to go out and vote mm-hmm
Judson Hembree says do you think bernie
is ahead of his time or is this the peak
of the progressive movement I don't
believe this is the peak of the
progressive movement but I do believe
that the progressive movement is not
going to be carried forward by a 77 year
old who calls himself a Democratic
Socialist and uses revolutionary
language I think that the time has
passed for that branding but I don't
believe that the time has even started
started for the progressive movement
we've got a hype train going on twitch
very exciting get a job dude seriously
has subscribed with twitch prime which I
very much appreciate let's see what the
coverage is looking like on what are we
watching here ABC
what is this ABC News is not even
covering the voting it's very very
strange I wish we had some other stream
it just seems like Washington Post isn't
isn't doing the thing let me see here
yeah YouTube is recommending my stream
for people looking for election results
which is crazy YouTube must really be
malfunctioning if it's recommending
people watch this right hard to hard to
imagine let's see here
PBS Newshour what could possibly be
happening on Sky News it's got to be a
mess right oh my god I'm not even gonna
put it up for you guys because it's
crazy it's absolutely crazy what's
happening on Sky News there's Illinois
primary analysis which is a local news
station we definitely don't want that
there really aren't a lot of streams
right now interestingly enough do people
not care about tonight's primaries
that's a weird that's a weird thing to
imagine there's a DW stream which is not
talking even remotely about tonight's
elections that's interesting
yeah nobody else is suggesting people
who are saying some people got banned
okay I don't think that that's affecting
what's going on here okay very good
all right let's reset where we are as we
close in on the top of the hour if
you're just joining us there were four
elections scheduled for today
those were Florida Illinois Arizona and
Ohio Ohio with their Republican governor
Mike DeWine postponed the election a lot
of debate over that um was it the right
thing from a public health perspective
yes was it also a Republican governor
trying to prevent the start of a blue
wave maybe I don't know in any case
Ohio's not voting in Florida Joe Biden
has won and he is currently leading by
39 in the vote count Tulsi with half a
percent in Illinois Joe Biden has won
currently with 7% reporting he is
leading by a twenty six Tulsi with 0.4
percent and Arizona polls will be
closing at the top of the hour at 10:00
p.m. the updated delegate numbers have
Joseph R Biden Jr 282 and 282 delegates
ahead of Bernie Sanders and listen you
know I don't want to everybody should do
what's best for them Bernie should drop
out tonight that's the reality it's the
the risk to people's health of going out
and voting at this point when Bernie has
no path to the nomination I don't
believe it makes sense the five people
waiting for Tulsi to win you know I
don't want that I want to protect that
those five people as well and Tulsi now
with two delegates you know what I have
to apologize to you guys
two months ago I said I don't believe
Tulsi has a path to a single delegate
and I was wrong she had a path to two
delegates and for that I apologize
sincerely apologize to everybody here so
so more than likely again the right
thing to do would be for Bernie Sanders
to
to drop out tonight or drop out tonight
or tomorrow if you're just joining us
first welcome we are live on Facebook
live twitch and YouTube if you're
watching on YouTube please make sure to
LIKE and subscribe like and subscribe
yesterday during the stream we hit eight
hundred and fifteen thousand YouTube
subscribers and if just 15% of you
subscribed right now we would get to
eight hundred and sixteen 816 YouTube
subscribers it really does make a
difference so please make sure that you
are like and subscribe and then most
maybe most importantly we have this
thing called membership you go to my
website join pakman.com infos all right
there beautiful website you sign up you
use the coupon code 20/20 now you save
66% my staff laughs at me for offering
such large discounts but most
importantly we start to fill up this bar
we have a goal of 25 new members we're
only at 5 and it would it could be the
end of the show it could be so
embarrassing if we were to finish out
the night with only five new members I
hope it doesn't happen it could be ugly
could get very very very very ugly
alright I see people who I'm
filibustering but I see other people
sending sending super chats here let me
see here okay nunya bidness said label
me a Bernie bro if you want to alienate
me
okay bull rot says David for some reason
I can't send the text I wanted to okay
avi Schiffman created a very cool global
stat site he's only 17 okay you know
what I think my dad sent me this site
the other day let's take a look
oh yeah I saw this it's amazing that a
17 year old did it I think that there
are better visualizations I think this
one is pretty good this is the a RC GIS
dashboard
I think the
one's pretty good and I also think that
the world ometer x' 1 continues to be
very very good I've been looking at
world ah meters very strongly and I
think it I think it's good but I
appreciate the recommendation
Gustavo Morales says did you vote for
mockery no I haven't voted in Argentina
I haven't lived there since I was five
years old I haven't voted there
Gustavo Morales says should there be a
max age to be president minimum is 35
conceptually there probably should in
some sense but realistically you know
adding requirements limiting presidents
president adding presidential
requirements is a very difficult thing
to do and I don't I don't think it's uh
it's going out it's going to happen
Drew's ale says funny how people are
blaming media bias for Bernie's lost
when the media was so against Trump in
2016 yet he's still won it makes you
wonder yeah listen I mean look at let's
look at the popular vote count again
Biden is now winning by nearly two point
1 million votes you know that that
people are voting for Biden we just have
to realize it he's not progressive we
don't like it etc oh good ABC News has
now picked up let's see what what ABC
News has going
nothing
I had just talked over this music okay
um video diaries yes okay all right so
here's one thing I'm interested in
oh hold on a second let me let me
actually let me just skip right to this
last this super chat this is I love this
stuff
Augustine says you say you don't care
about Tulsi but you keep bringing her up
in videos and livestreams promise me
you'll stop both of you are getting old
and annoying listen I get a lot of hate
mail about Tulsi about talking about
Tulsi and I react to it but I mean she's
one of the three people getting votes
tonight right I'm just telling you what
vote count she has the idea that I'm you
know continuing to bring her up
unprovoked as weird like she is running
I don't really get it but but she is
running so listen we've decentralized
production of the David Pakman show to
be the good guys to be good guy David
Pakman show and to be helping with
social distancing and all that stuff you
may find it fascinating how I have
rigged up the entire setup in my home so
what I'm thinking of doing if people are
interesting is Friday almost doing about
a full behind-the-scenes tour of this
studio I've even put together a PVC pipe
lighting grid okay Sam cedar as many of
you know built a lighting went we
probably all know but anyways Sam cedar
built a lighting grid in his studio and
he used two inch plumbing pipe and I
went when I was talking to about it he
said he dropped the piece of pipe on his
head and almost was concussed and that
made me think you know I'm just hanging
lights if I get some good PVC pipe it's
probably strong enough and nobody risks
slamming themselves in the head and I
did it and it's a beautiful lighting
grid I looked at the PVC pipe very
strongly and it's doing everything I
need it to do so anyway Friday or you
know I'm I'm quarantined so maybe
Saturday I will maybe do like a behind
the scenes a tour of this let me say
thank you to Frances grig
who was new member number six tonight at
join pakman.com as the results continue
to come in super chats continue to come
in um let's see it body body says giving
vote to a party regardless of the
nominee takes away the bargaining chip
we have against them they should earn
the votes and not expect it no no I'm
not vote blue no matter who I'm not
saying vote for the Democratic nominee
no matter who it is I'm saying knowing
that it's going to be VY Biden Biden is
better than Trump this is not you know
people need to people need to pull up
their big boy pants and realize vote
blue no matter who you can debate it but
that's a very different thing what I'm
saying is it's Biden versus Trump
I prefer Biden Supreme Court picks
better tax plan than Trump supports the
green new deal on his website would not
be an international embarrassment so
it's not vote blue no matter who it's we
know who it's going to be it's going to
be Biden vote for him
not vote blue no matter who okay Eric
says any idea who the next progressive
superstar is going to be no I don't know
Kyle Kyle s'en says do you think aoc
would succeed where Bernie failed she
might but she might fail in other places
as well we've got to think it we've got
to think it through and there will be
plenty of time to do that also-rans says
you probably also know the re xx is a
great kick drum Mike yeah I have seen I
have seen the re xx used to mic up kick
drums Eric Lamont says this 2020 primary
proved the 2016 problem was Hillary
Rodham Clinton I'd need to know more
about in what sense you mean that Jessi
says Bernie must drop out spread will be
on his hands
yeah that's you're probably right M gray
says felt sick for about one and a half
weeks for no reason in January yeah you
know I think it let's I'm gonna put a
tweet together about that and I would
love it if you guys retweeted it let me
say let me
how I should say this I had a mild cough
for ten days weeks ago plus headache
lots of friends mentioned the same
possible these were all almost
asymptomatic coronavirus cases we need
an antibody test to know who is now
immune there we go
please retweet where that that went that
disappeared oh I need to go oh I see
here we go you Backman
there it is whoa just popped off the
screen anyway that's a little something
if folks want to want to grab and also
if you have had a similar thing so for
example em gray please reply to this
tweet with your your story because I
think it would be very interesting if we
can know we can sort of amplify that to
some degree
okay results continue to come in the
margin has narrowed in Illinois now down
to only a 20 point lead for Joe Biden
which I believe is exactly where the
polling was going in and then we ran our
from Arizona results as well if you're
just joining us on YouTube remember to
Like and subscribe
both are very much appreciated let me
say thank you and welcome to Ono now the
names are starting to get complicated
okay Brad durak is new member number
seven tonight
Horace courtier or Cordier
is new member number eight tonight and
Jatin bill Moria Jatin bill Maria Jatin
bill Moria I'm going with is new member
number nine tonight at join pakman.com
thank you so much Jatin I appreciate
your support the dude says I see too
many left knees ranting about unfairness
rather than being introspective that's
no way to build a progressive movement
in my opinion check out my video on
YouTube why Bernie lost I believe I am
being the right balance of introspective
and other
stuff I guess I would say quirky quips
says on Twitter there are a few cities
where Italians are playing and singing
on their balconies music heals I saw
that very nice to see Jordan Collison
Jordan Hollister says koban 19 fears
Jesse Lee Peterson okay Lauro and pareil
says what is your biggest disagreement
with Bernie I think that his
medicare-for-all plan will cost a lot
more than he thinks
I think that's my biggest disagreement
Augustine says you say you don't care
about okay oh I read that one before
okay Junie McGraw says Tom Brady is on
the Bucs now what are your thoughts is
that true Tom Brady Buccaneers that's
fascinating
he reportedly will sign good for Tom
Brady you know listen we're dealing with
crises that right now he can do whatever
he wants we've got our what is it six
Super Bowls here thanks to Trump
dishwasher Trump's dishwasher who
subscribed with twitch Prime I
appreciate that thanks to Ren Diggs for
subscribing with twitch prime thanks to
sha Zhi cool for subscribing with twitch
prime as well
a Len a--the says I feel the progressive
movement isn't going to gain a foothold
until many Republicans are forced from
Congress by the march of time not
elections what are your thoughts I think
it's gonna be a mix of the two quite
frankly there will be an aging out of
more conservative people but I think
it's gonna be a combination of the two
alvaro bazan says warren lost all
progressive credibility for me sad that
it mate that may be it for Warren Pedro
Augusta Marcus says in Brazil bolson ro
is suspected of having Cove at 19 and is
calling anti-congress protests and going
around shaking everyone's hands and
taking selfies yeah he's he's an
irresponsible a clown unfortunately and
he's I would expect him to continue
doing that
Matthew Long says Biden's website says
he supports green new deal as a
framework better than Trump and Joseph
Holly has grabbed a soy boy subscription
Frank and Garrett is now a soy boy Tammy
M says if Bernie drops out at this point
what about all the voters who
even have a chance to cast the ballot it
seems unfair I get it but but listen
there are already voters who don't have
a chance to cast the ballot for Budaj
edge because he dropped out this is how
primaries work candidates drop out by
that logic no one should ever drop out
when we look at again when we look at
the delegate count which it looks like
we're still at a to 8 a to 82 Bernie
cannot recover from a 282 delegate
deficit and at this point when we are
actually saying it's a public health
liability to go out and have large
groups of people voting we should have
vote by mail we should have online
voting we don't it's not going to get
set up in 3 weeks
Bernie has no path and the safe thing to
do to encourage social isolation social
distancing and and self isolation is for
Bernie to say I lost I I don't have a
path and that's that's the unfortunate
that's the unfortunate reality did I
just did I uh oh there's a speech going
on did somebody say them Reese okay no I
missed those somebody's trolling me I
think okay anyway I have I tweeted about
coronavirus cases Oh 29 of you actually
retweeted it thank you very much yeah I
had a mild cough for ten days weeks ago
plus headache friends mentioned the same
this might have been an asymptomatic
coronavirus case we really need an
antibody test to know who is now immune
add your reply at a retweet add a like
do do whatever feels good to you at this
point in time okay other thank-yous
David Roby is new member number ten
today at join pakman.com and Edie
Schindler is new member number 11x join
pakman.com free association the last
name Schindler reminds me of Schindler's
List which reminds me of the Amazon
series hunters where Al Pacino plays a
Nazi hunter I'm about five episodes in
could not recommend it highly enough it
is just excellent I mean just absolutely
excellent excellent series
that I encourage you to check out Kindle
lover has gifted a twitch subscription
mister relu has subscribed with Prime
and says already a member on your
website but here's something a bit extra
with twitch prime thank you for all you
do keep up the good work
thank you mister relu i really do
appreciate your support very much so car
says vote-by-mail
we still have paperless machines I think
you mean paper machines don't you
Jonathan McCartney says in this
essentially the death is this
essentially the death of the progressive
movement for the time being no I don't
think so I mean listen I I think that
you will see the series is hunters on
Amazon Prime guys I think you will see
some Democrats win some some read Senate
seats that'll push the Senate to the
left I think you may see a progressive
is asian in the house but you're either
going to see Biden or Trump reelected
and that that's going to be what it is
and then we've got then we've got 2022
let me say thank you and welcome to Ryan
Wright who is new member number twelve
this evening and oh I love this name
muffy Dayton muffy Dayton that sounds
like a UH that that sounds like a a
private investigator in a Raymond
Chandler novel Muffy Dayton is new
member number thirteen tonight at join
pakman.com very much appreciate that
let's get you caught up if you're just
joining us if you are just joining us
for primaries were scheduled for tonight
Ohio which has been postponed because of
kovat 19 Florida Illinois and Arizona
Florida has been called for Joe Biden
Illinois has been called for Joe Biden
and Arizona polls close at 10:00 p.m.
and we have updated delegate numbers Joe
Biden currently leading by 282 delegates
the official coronavirus number of cases
198 to 41 very relevant
and realistically the worldwide number
is probably in the millions I don't
think it would be an overstatement to
infer that the real number of
coronavirus cases is probably in the
millions at at this point in time okay
first in last kappa says hey david i
tweeted you about some illegal
activities in some chicago voting booths
i think it would interest you my twitter
feed is almost completely unusable
because of the number of messages i get
sometimes even my verified feed gets out
of control it would be best if you send
an email using the website contact form
on my website and then we will triage
we will triage it David Gardner says
America will be the next Wuhan I hope
not I hope not and that's why we all we
all need to do our parts let me see what
people are saying on Twitter I tweeted
about what might have been me having
coronavirus weeks ago let's see what
people are saying fever is in the vast
majority of cases no fever is in the
vast majority of diagnosed cases I don't
know that this guy is being responsible
and I'm actually going to respond to be
clear fever is in the majority of
symptomatic and diagnosed cases right
the NBA players testing positive with
with no symptoms have no fever but have
the virus right not sure why this keeps
being repeated yeah I think that people
are missing the boat on this in South
Korea they tested funny tweet from an
account I muted love it again in South
Korea they tested large populations of
young people 20 to 29 a ton of them had
no symptoms and had corona virus in fact
I should mention that also South Korea
tested large numbers of a symptom
medic young people 20 to 29 and found
many had the virus that's strong right
guys you support me in this battle
against some random dude on Twitter who
is this person I have no idea who okay
I don't I don't know who they are but in
any case stop making your readers think
there oh come on dude we're talking like
adults here give me a break this guy
doesn't know what's going on
I share a similar story do some googling
on reinfection from what I'm reading
people are immune for presumably at
least a year from what I'm seeing from
medical sources that was the Democrat
hoax possible but doubtful I have a
light cough lift the sanctions on Cuba
same is true for all viruses before you
get a vaccine you don't need unlikely
but you're correct we need an antibody
test I hope you didn't spread it most
people will get it since there's no one
who has built any immunity we just don't
want to get it all at once a person
recut the virus my understanding is that
that oh it was faulty testing it was a
false negative for virus protect deepak
at all costs I had terrible pneumonia
for a week started feeling better got
ill with a fever vomiting diarrhea two
to three days shortly after outlets
began reporting it yeah listen I I think
that this guy is actually saying
something irresponsible by saying if you
he's essentially saying if you don't
have a fever you don't have it when the
truth appears to be very very different
very very different I don't like what
that guy is saying I think he's
spreading some serious disinformation
there which is not good not good for us
okay Shawn flower says David you said a
centrist winning the nomination and
losing to trump may be best for the
progressive movement long-term what are
your thoughts on this yeah it would be
terrible for the country for four years
for the progressive movement as a team
it might be best to check out my video
on it Lauro imperial says what's your
chess elo rating uh elo I think is an
official rating I don't have any
official rating I'm rated like 1300 on
Lee chess which is where I play I don't
know how much
that tells us azim Abu Khalil says would
or would it not be in Trump's best
interest to resolve the domestic kovat
nine situation ASAP I believe it would
in fact I actually believe if Trump does
resolve it he almost certainly sails to
re-election I don't care about the
political implications it needs to be
solved right away but I recognized that
there's a good chance Trump solidifies
re-election if he is seen as perceived
as dealing with it properly so far it's
been a freaking disaster 21st century
Mao says David I'm worried about your
followers saying don't vote Biden will
you say staying home in 2020 will elect
Trump
yeah I've been saying it I've been
saying it and I will keep saying it
Christie Sparkman has also grabbed a soy
boy level YouTube subscription okay I
guess people are going after this guy
let me see
so this guy went after me and let's see
I responded and yeah okay good I think
this guy has absolutely no leg to stand
on whatsoever
feel free to adjudicate this yourself
but this is this is the battle that I'm
referring to that it's taking place on
Twitter right now you can't say what the
symptoms are based on confirmed cases
because we know of so many asymptomatic
cases and and that's that I think we're
done with that I don't think we need to
be hearing more about that at this point
in time okay let's see I want to say
thanks to a few other people Zachary
Adkins is new member number 14 tonight
at join pakman.com and that's it okay 14
very good thanks also to Tam I am for
grabbing a youtube subscription I am
gonna do a water refill we'll see what's
happening on ABC and then we'll be back
only 45 minutes until Arizona closes
Democratic Party really go toe to toe
with the state's about these the
shake-up to the primary schedule the
National Party is really worried that
states are going to delay
primary's to the point that it could
really start to influence the
conventions in the summer if those
conventions do take place so far we've
heard the National Party really instead
urge all the states to look at other
emergency measures vote-by-mail absentee
voting look I think when all of this is
said and done we're going to have a huge
national conversation about whether
voting by mail should be made possible
for everyone across the country and just
quickly Mary Alice I mean if anybody
knows the Sanders campaign it's you a
former embed there do you think of it
Sanders is gonna throw in the towel
anytime soon potentially you know I was
really surprised by what I saw in that
debate stage on Sunday I went into that
debate expecting that Bernie Sanders was
really going to use the time to try to
advance his ideas and instead we saw him
there ready to fight and go toe to toe
with the former vice president he was
picking apart Joe Biden's record on
Social Security really trying to argue
that Joe Biden might have electability
vulnerabilities I'm not sure that he
landed that case but he didn't look to
me like someone that was planning to
wrap his campaign soon all right Mary
Alice parks thank you as always
appreciate your time and now we turn to
the corona virus outbreak and the
massive stimulus plan potentially in the
works president trump proposing to
directly send cash to americans as part
of a possible 850 billion to one
trillion dollar plan this is more
Americans risk losing their jobs and
their financial security as the country
continues to shut down the mayor of New
York City today floating the idea of a
shelter-in-place order as the death toll
nationwide has now topped 100 but it's
far worse in Italy the surging death
toll there from kovat 19 has now
exceeded 2,500 and growing concerns for
the safety of health care workers on the
frontlines of this crisis what is the
government doing to address dangerous
shortages of life-saving protective gear
all this happening as those three states
hold primaries but first we go to John
Karl at the White House as the US
economy continues to falter John is
tracking president Trump's far-reaching
proposals to ease the economic pain
facing one of the biggest economic
crises in American history President
Trump is urging Congress to inject up to
a trillion
dollars into the economy one big piece
of the plan which is still being
negotiated direct cash payments to most
Americans ABC News has been talking to
some of those hit hardest including
parents of the nearly 30 million
children who rely on schools most of
which are now closed for low-cost or
free lunches tell me how life is at home
right now it's scary the kids don't
understand
you know it's trying to explain to the
kids is the biggest part like you know
this is serious right now this is the
new normal now Amy tonight many are
without work because their employers
have been forced to shut down including
the more than 7 million people who work
in restaurants and bars so in total how
many employees are used to 200 have they
confided in you about worried about rent
and paying bills you can see fear nice
because here the administration says it
wants to start sending out checks to
Americans right away it's unclear how
much those checks would be for Senator
Mitt Romney has proposed $1,000 per
person
Americans need cash now and the
president wants to get cash now and I
mean now in the next two weeks the
emerging trillion dollar plan would also
include relief for the industry's hit
hardest including hotels and airlines
which have asked for fifty billion
dollars there's also a measure to allow
people an extra 90 days to pay their
taxes without penalty or an all right we
are back and we are continuing to follow
tonight's election numbers and so far
they are very very very bad for Bernie
Sanders although he has pulled within 18
in Illinois but of course it has been
called for Joe Biden already presumably
the exit polls are very very one-sided
extremely extremely one-sided if you're
just joining us on Twitter Facebook live
and YouTube Florida and Illinois called
for Joe Biden waiting for Arizona at the
top of the hour
Ohio of course postponing their primary
Joe Biden now just the hair shy of a 2.1
million vote margin on Bernie Sanders
that is where we are we've also been
arguing with people on Twitter about
different things and it looks like a
bunch of people are going after this guy
and yeah that's that that's that's
pretty interesting he is he is talking
down to me right stop being
irresponsible with your platform I
should maybe mute that guy but I'm not
going to I'm gonna let him continue
continue sending me messages of
different kinds okay other super chats
that are coming in let's see here
farmer Kip says are you keeping up with
the candidates tournament if so who you
got winning also look up the picture
feed a took there was a crowd all packed
together I have not kept up with any
chess over the last few days so I don't
have any idea what's going on our rich
ropa thak says WrestleMania 36 will
emanate from an empty gym don't know
anything about it don't do any you know
pro wrestling stuff myself first in last
Papa says okay David I sent a message
through your contact info crates
Ryan manake how worried are you about
people in power using kovat to oppress
people I am worried about it I am
worried about it it doesn't diminish the
reality and seriousness of it but it is
a concern
Susan Dover Latham sends a super chap
jason pope sends a super chap the
Beckman ATAR says David I'm not so sure
Trump will be able to pick RBG's
replacement if he wins re-election but
Dems take the Senate and keep the House
this year they could block any and all
of his picks until Adam gets into the
White House maybe wet when half Dems
shown that that sort of spine though
Shannon Bennis is David are you a
hypochondriac like me tough times then
no I think I've already had two
coronavirus I don't think I have it but
what do I know let me say thank you and
welcome to Christie Sparkman who is new
member number 15 tonight at join
pakman.com and Jessi Guerrero is new
member number 16 tonight at join
pakman.com that puts us just 9 new
members away from hitting our goal of a
25 and remember if you're watching on
twitch very much appreciate our twitch
viewers make sure to follow grab a
twitch Prime subscription if if you so
please as we get to the last 40 minutes
before the top of the hour
Arizona results come in again reviewing
so far in Florida we have Biden at plus
39 exactly where he was polling in
Illinois we have Biden at plus 19 a hey
I think that's a hair shy of where he
was polling and Arizona in play polls
close in 40 minutes 40 minutes their
updated delegate numbers we've been here
for a little bit this is a 282 delegate
lead for Joseph R Biden Jr here's a
question to everybody in the chat if
this is the delegate gap roughly at the
end of the night should Bernie draw
now and that is not only assessing
what's going on in the primary but
considering the public health situation
with the primaries and people voting if
Bernie's down to 82 should he drop out
let me take a look at the chat here
most people saying yes a few people
saying no seems like yes it's
overwhelmingly yeses with a few noes
spur and interspersed now some of the
noes are coming in hmm interesting it
seems it's probably 75% he should drop
out and 25% he should not
III expect that bernie is going to
suspend tomorrow I think if I had if I
was a betting man which I'm not I would
bet that Bernie probably probably
suspends tomorrow the way that these
these numbers are coming in so far a
Florida almost completely counted an
Illinois now at 20% yeah more yeses the
knows although I see I see the knows as
well all right let's do a straw poll how
about that straw poll here we go and
create a poll I'll post this if bernie
is down to 50-plus delegates tonight
should he suspend his campaign answer
options yes he should suspend no he
should not suspend very good let's do it
and here's the link let me paste it in
on twitch there it is and then I'm
pasting it in on YouTube as well and
let's go straight to the results in my
experience when people do this on
streams people just make it get to 50%
just because they think it's funny but
we'll see we'll see if that happens now
it doesn't seem to be updating live
that's weird
I wish it did
would be more fun yeah about two to one
so far people believe that Bernie should
suspend that would that's funny when I
eyeballed it it looked like 7525 but I
guess it's more like 65 35 roughly
interesting and yeah alright so it looks
like looks like the audience right now
which is disproportionately Bernie
supporters from my read believes by
about a two-to-one margin roughly that
if Bernie Sanders is down to 50 plus he
should suspend his campaign let's see
here 425 for 58 interesting that not
that many people want to vote oh okay
let me let me paste the link I see a few
people are still asking for the link I'm
pasting it in the YouTube chat and I've
pasted it at multiple times and I'm
pasting it now in twitch chat as well
I'm sorry for the people watching on
Facebook that I can't paste it there but
with the tools that Facebook provides
are just not that good maybe that'll get
us some more votes 6237 okay I think
this gives us a sense roughly sixty
forty or sixty five thirty five folks
are thinking bernie probably should
suspend if he is down more than two
hundred and fifty delegates at the end
of the night okay
all right very good I think we can get
away from that at this point in time and
see what else is going on okay new
members to thank Ono I don't have anyone
how sad is that
that's disappointing I'll get back to
thanking folks soon we are at sixteen of
25 members I trust we'll be back to that
very very soon okay
Martin's ideas Emporium says if Bernie's
too polite vital to have alpha leader
maybe maybe it depends on the person
needs to be genuine I think is the
important thing
alluro Imperial says should the
Falklands be part of Argentina
you're not going to go
me into that and the truth is I don't
know enough about the history to really
competently comment Farouk says keep up
the good work David from the United
Kingdom thank you fork and hope you are
hope you're staying safe there by the
way how crazy how quickly let's take a
break from these election results just
momentarily I mean they'll continue to
come in and we'll see them I have been
struck or stricken as some like to say
now I I've been I was struck by in three
days everything changes in our society
in three days I walk by my cafe and
restaurant favorite hot spots in Boston
there's no tables and chairs many are
closed with a sign that says closed
until further notice many will not come
back some are open for take-out you're
walking down the street and as people
are walking towards each other they move
to opposite edges of the sidewalk to
pass each other this is in Boston I know
in Florida people are partying at the
beach and spreading covin but in
Massachusetts okay people pass each
other on the street with the maximum
amount of space I always if I see
someone coffin to the air I I cross the
street and just walk away but you go
anywhere and when you leave people say
stay safe stay healthy it's like in an
instant our lives have been completely
and totally adjusted I see people from
Norway and Finland saying that's always
how it is here that is funny yeah
but that is very very quickly things
change we've almost built walls in our
minds around ourselves in in in some way
shape or form philosophy and critical
thinking says what is your advice for
progressives in the future my worry is
that if Biden beats Trump the narrative
will be that things are all better now
and progressive reforms are unnecessary
this is exactly why I said Biden beating
Trump would be good for the country
compared to four more years of Trump but
probably not good for the progressive
movement Bob Adkins says wife is from
Ueno situs Zachary Adkins you're great
very nice
say hello to her Ryan manake says if you
lived in Chicago would you have gone out
and voted tonight you know I probably
would have I probably would have because
I don't know I would have balanced the
importance of participating in our
democracy versus the risk of getting or
spreading coronavirus I think if
Massachusetts was voting today and they
didn't suspend I probably would have
voted and it may not have been
responsible they're not testing anyone
here as far as I know and a few high
schools have been exposed I'm not
risking it I understand that a DD says
when's your pseudo science series
dropping I thought it already did
carpe Donnelly says still impressed by
Democratic turnout people just want
someone to vote for to beat Trump and
vote blue all the way down the ticket
Sanders was never going to be the guy
they just needed someone to emerge
someone to emerge all right that is that
is that is a view that is a position
that people have not not something
everybody is going to agree with let me
say thank you to tabe or snapping for
gifting five community subscriptions
very much appreciate that rot Cruz has
cheered with some bits as well which I
very much appreciate as well thank you
so much we have Florida and Illinois
called for Joseph R Biden Jr we are
waiting on Arizona and Ohio has
suspended Ohio has suspended let's see
if we have any new election results
streams that we might be able to pick up
not that many people streaming tonight
it's interesting I don't know I don't
know exactly why uh-oh did we just lose
did we just lose the stream oh no we
didn't lose that we didn't lose this oh
we lost all of them oh no that was weird
did you YouTube seem to sort of glitch
briefly that's very odd did the action
did I stop screaming they're weird
YouTube's going down okay I think we're
back I think we're back all right very
good that was scary for a second I
thought I was losing the stream oh okay
Joe Biden oh we are awaiting Joe Biden
to serve who is going to speak shortly
let's see here and that is going to be
interesting we will see what he has to
say we'll keep an eye I'll turn the
volume up there so that we hear that as
soon as that starts and what else do we
have I guess that's really it as far as
what's going on we're gonna wait on Joe
Biden and we should be hearing it from
him soon people asking when is it over
listen I believe it's over tonight and I
believe Bernie Sanders will drop out by
tomorrow let's see the final results
from the straw poll 62% of my audience
believes Bernie should suspend his
campaign based on the results so far 37
38 percent believed that he should not
okay so that's that's where the audience
is and we will soon see something soon
see something from Joe Biden speaking
about tonight's results okay other Super
chats that are coming in let's see here
machine XP over in Western Mass lots of
doctors offices are not testing for mild
symptoms numbers are most likely wildly
inaccurate absolutely absolutely
Charlie says 66% membership savings is
disgusting our discounts that deep even
legal come on and you know funny story
about that see how if you look up there
it says save 66% with coupon 2020 now
the only way I'm getting away with a
coupon code that big is because
regulators are too concerned with kovat
to pay attention to my deep discounts
under normal circumstances if I offered
a 66% discount I would have regulators
beating down my door and just destroying
the studio throwing my microphone in the
trash they'd say it's too big but
because of kovat they're just not not
really paying attention and that's why
you can save 66 percent okay
bong leach has subscribed with twitch
prime which I very much
we are standing by waiting for Joe Biden
we are continuing to see results come in
a lot of focus on coronavirus and of
course Ohio postponing their primary we
are just moments away 27 minutes I guess
from polls closing in Arizona and we'll
see whether whether the numbers are
close there or or what goes down Dee
Smitty says did you see the news about
Tom Brady if so what are your thoughts
good coverage as usual yes Tom Brady
leaving the Patriots to the Buccaneers
and you know it's it's been a good run I
don't know that he's gonna do that great
at the Buccaneers but that's his
business
my friends Ryan manake says is there any
value in Bernie staying ill until the
end
also I'm a u-tube member would it be
better if I migrated to your website
well we keep a larger share of payments
on my website because we pay a tiny
slice to quote Andrew yang when you sign
up on my website we pay a bigger slice
it's like a machete anof a big slice
when people sign up anywhere else that's
that's the unfortunate reality thank you
to this Bend per ticket for the soy boy
membership Frei salt says do you support
vote blue no matter what
no I support vote for Biden over Trump I
don't do stuff like vote blue no matter
who I do support Biden over Trump
because that's what we're dealing with
this particular time around and that's
that's as far as I can go I don't think
Biden will reach out to progressives he
may not he may not and that may be very
very bad for him we will have to see o
our people says my website crashed let
me double check that it's it's always
horrible when that happens in the middle
of a stream sometimes a whole bunch of
people try to get memberships at once
and the website crashes no it does seem
to be up it does seem to be up it's just
a little bit a little bit slow
Rasmus Hamaker says how do you donate
plasma to the lizard post I have no idea
what that even means I couldn't possibly
tell you what
you're talking about I don't know I
don't know what that is
we're standing by for Joe Biden Joe
Biden expected to speak at some point
soon despite the fact that he is always
very very late to his own events and
we'll see we'll see if and when he shows
up reviewing the delegate numbers Bernie
Sanders currently experiencing a two
hundred and what what is that of 60 120
180 - yeah 282 282 delegate deficit
that's that's starting to get sizable
what else have we done tonight I got
into a big argument with some guy on
Twitter let's see what people have
responded with to this guy who said
there's no asymptomatic cases
essentially you okay this guy seems
furious with me okay
let's do a Richmond porn of course all
right very good
people are just arguing and I guess
that's that's totally fine people can
continue to argue okay breaking news
let's see see news projects that Joe
Biden will win the Illinois Democratic
primary that's the top of his Florida
projected win we knew that we are going
to go now to Mary Alice who joins us
again in DC tonight Mary Alice I don't
think this comes as a surprise right the
Illinois and the Florida victories for
Joe Biden no not a surprise and it's
good to see that we're getting election
results on schedule you know there were
a lot of polling places in Illinois that
actually had to extend their hours
because of some long lines we saw these
states have to scramble today in the
wake of the virus they had to close some
polling locations send voters to
different locations three measures to
keep the polling locations safe and and
clean so that voters felt confident to
vote so I am grateful that people did
feel comfortable that they could that
they could go cast their vote exercise
it's important right of theirs
and that we're seeing solid results come
out in an orderly and timely fashion and
Devin Dwyer your reaction I wanted to
get if do we have Devin yeah Devin
curious if you're surprised that voter
turnout was so yeah I am significant I
mean in many ways I guess people also
mailed in ballots or voted early as well
yeah I talked to voter advocates earlier
today
Lindsey in Illinois in Arizona they were
surprised to see the numbers as strong
as they were and a lot of those
advocates do credit the early voting
initiatives all right so we knew most of
that stuff and we are standing by for
Joe Biden looking like any moment we are
going to hear from him in the meantime
let me say thank you to a few folks who
have just signed up first of all thank
you to Inga fonder who is new member
number 17 tonight let me say thank you
to Kevin Ferretti who is new member
number 18 tonight
Tamara Thompkins is new member number 19
tonight and Omni liberal gang also known
as Kyle Benjamin is new member number oh
sorry not 10 20 and here is Joseph our
by Miller a good evening everyone last
week had the honor of speaking to all of
you from Philadelphia the birthplace of
the foundational documents of our
democracy tonight in keeping with the
latest guidance from the CDC to avoid
gatherings of more than 10 people I'm
speaking to you from my home in
Wilmington Delaware and I hope all of
you are staying safe talking and taking
the recommended the recommended
precautions and talking to the docs Yuma
if you have one to keep your social
distance to slow the spread of this
virus this pandemic has impacted every
aspect of our lives and every aspect of
this campaign most of all my heart goes
out to all of those who have lost a
loved one to those who have contracted
the virus to all the brave Americans who
are working harder than ever
they're neighbors so all those children
are home from school that are worried
and don't know quite why doctors nurses
EMTs and public health officials as well
as the frontline emergency workers like
firefighters and dedicated folks working
to keep the shelves stocked in the
grocery stores you know tackling this
pandemic is the national emergency akin
to fighting a war it's going to require
leadership and cooperation from every
level of government and it's gonna
require us to move thoughtfully and
decisively to quickly address both the
public health crisis as well as the
economic crisis it's gonna require us to
pay attention to the medical and
scientific and health experts and as to
require each of us to do our part yes
this is a moment where we need our
leaders to lead but it's also a moment
where the choices and decisions we make
as individuals are gonna collectively
impact on what happens make a big
difference in the severity this outbreak
and the ability of our medical and
hospital systems to handle it you know I
know we as a people are up to this
challenge we always have been I know the
whole answer this moment of crisis with
the best that we find in all of us
because that's what Americans always
don't have done and what we do that's
who we are
ordinary people doing extraordinary
things when the need arises and today
we're moving quickly to adapt to our
routines to meet this challenge
Americans in three states went to the
polls today I want to thank all the
public officials and the poll workers
who work closely with the public health
authorities to assure safe opportunities
for voting to clean and disinfect voting
booths and to make sure the voters could
cast their ballots while maintaining the
distance from one another was safe you
know it's important for us to get
through this crisis protecting both the
public health and our democracy today it
looks like once again in Florida in
Illinois we're still waiting to hear
from Arizona our campaign has had a very
good night we move closer to securing
the Democratic Party's nomination for
president
and we're doing it by building a broad
coalition that we need to win in
November with strong support from the
african-american community a Latino
community high school does of people
educated people like the folks I grew up
with in my old neighborhood labor
teachers suburban women veterans
firefighters and so many more and we're
doing it with a common vision senator
Sanders and I may disagree on tactics
but we share a common vision for the
need to provide affordable health care
for all Americans reduce income inequity
that has risen so drastically to
tackling the existential threat of our
time climate change senator Sanders and
his supporters have brought a remarkable
passion and tenacity to all of these
issues together they have shifted the
fundamental conversation in this country
so let me say especially to the young
voters who have been inspired by senator
Sanders if I hear you I know it's at
stake I know what we have to do our goal
is a campaign and my goal is a candidate
for president is to unify this party and
then to unify the nation you know it's
the moments like these we realized we
need to put politics aside and work
together as Americans the coronavirus
doesn't care if you're a democrat or
republican it will not discriminate
based on national origin race gender or
your zip code and will touch people in
positions of power as well as the most
vulnerable people in our society we're
all this together this is moment for
each of us to see and believe the best
in every one of us to look out for our
neighbor to understand the fear and
stress and so many are feeling to care
for the elderly the only couple down the
street to thank the health care worker
the doctors the nurses the pharmacist
their grocery store cashier and the
people restocking the shelves to believe
in one another because I assure you when
we do that when we see the best in each
of us we lift this nation up and we'll
get through this together that's how
we've always done it god bless you all
and my special prayer for those of you
frontlines of the crisis doctors nurses
health care workers caring for the virus
victims and their families my prayers
are going out for everyone my hopes are
high because I believe in times of
crisis Americans have always stepped up
we have to step up and care for one
another thank you all thank you all for
listening
there is Joe Biden oh thanks is this
supposed to be off thanks okay do they
know they're still streaming know if
there's having them walk off okay Wow
Wow and fade out okay all right so Joe
Biden I mean listen how do you do
anything other than mostly talk about
the virus at this point right I mean
it's like that's that's what's going on
it's you you you have to contextualise
everything in terms of the virus
interesting that Joe Biden is already
talking like he's won this thing and
he's just reaching out he's just saying
positive things about Bernie at this
point because there's no risk he won the
math is there and now now directly
trying to appeal as the case is to
Bernie voters if you're just joining us
we are about to reset all of the results
from tonight if you're just joining us
on Twitter remember to follow the
channel if you're joining us on YouTube
please please please hit that like
button and also hit the subscribe button
both are free and you can just start
pounding like subscribe like subscribe
beat those buttons into submission
because it costs you nothing and and it
really helps us quite a bit okay let me
say a few other thank you Steve cheer
heart true heart that's a tough one
Steve cheer heart is new member number
21 tonight very much appreciate that
thank you so much for signing up
appreciate your support also thanks to
death by goonch for the twitch prime sub
with the
keep up the good work David okay we are
15 minutes from Arizona results let's
reset where we are we had four elections
scheduled today
they were Florida Illinois Arizona and
Ohio Ohio was postponed by the
Republican governor there Mike DeWine
until sometime in a hold on a second
I'm sorry we just have to ban for
anti-semitism
there we go that happened quick there we
go okay that one caught my attention
didn't it it's been postponed until June
2nd as people are saying in the chat
Florida has been called for Joe Biden
big win Illinois has been called for Joe
Biden smaller win but still still you
know 21 is sizable Bernie will get
delegates in both Arizona in play and
polls close
just 14 minutes from now the current
delegate count is 11 21 to 839 we did a
poll earlier of my viewers should Bernie
end his campaign tonight if he ends up
down more than 250 delegates by a 62 to
38 margin you guys said yes you if this
if you haven't voted in this poll I will
paste the link right into the twitch
chat first and then subsequently into
the YouTube chat and you can add your
vote to this if you have an opinion and
you want to weigh in but by roughly a 60
to 237 margin folks saying if this is
the deficit for Bernie by the end of the
night he should probably suspend his
campaign climbing now a little bit to 63
63 37 roughly and that that seems to be
where folks Minds are mostly on this
slightly dealt a slightly different
delegate count everywhere you look this
is the ABC News delegate count all of
them varying varying marginally let's
get back to Super chats I see that I've
fallen dangerously behind a Justin
sangre says Biden is running on a more
progressed
platform than Hillary or Obama there are
still some victories with the
progressive movement moving the
Democratic platform more left
that's a pragmatic view which you will
be attacked viciously as a centrist
shill for espousing paradigm shift says
new viewer considering membership
convinced me listen if you like what we
do the best way to support it is to vote
with your dollars and we're not talking
about a lot of dollars and not only are
you doing something morally right and
ethically right by getting a membership
you get extra stuff including we do an
extra show with with my producer my
producer joins me in a member only show
every day just for our paid members and
the info for signing up is is right up
there Rasmus haymaker says how to
convince people Bernie's not a communist
listen if you need to convince someone
that Bernie's not a communist it's a
lost cause in the sense that anyone who
believes that is unlikely to be an ally
let me put it that way
just get people to vote instead ryan
manake says my friend voted tonight and
asked how often they cleaned the
machines and the worker there just
laughed according to her and you didn't
answer to my other question what happens
if Bernie stays in if Bernie stays in
more people probably get coronavirus and
Bernie still doesn't win that I mean
that's that's as realistic as I can be
window zombie says Trump is going to win
again sad you may be right
Lauro Imperial says are you still an
Argentinean citizen I don't know the
answer to that in the sense that I have
an Argentinean birth certificate I can
renew my Argentinean passport any time
I'm not a resident so I'm not required
to vote they have compulsory voting in
in Argentina so I don't know if I'm
still a citizen I should find out right
I know any time if I wanted to go back
and live there it could be done it would
just be many hours of bureaucratic
nightmares okay do we are we banning
people I'm getting it people are trying
to call my attention to the
at our we do we have anti-semitism more
I already just banned one person for
anti-semitism I'm curious what are
people getting out of control
let's see view deleted message hmm I
don't know what's going on but remember
we are very careful about banning we
only ban very very rarely but when we do
it we take it seriously because we we're
definitely running a running a tight
ship I love how people on Twitter saying
the chat is fine yet what's happening on
YouTube is the stuff of Horrors right
now if you could only see Martin's idea
Emporium says hi David who are your top
five favorite philosophers you know for
me it's so hard to compare the
old-school philosophers to you know 19th
and 20th century people I don't know
that I could really put together a list
for you off the top of my head I would I
would really have to think about it
thanks to Jay dubs for subscribing with
twitch prime very much appreciate that
Sheila Joe Kornblum says are you
concerned Trump will make Biden look
foolish in a debate Biden's easily
flustered and angered and Trump will use
that to his advantage it's certainly a
concern no doubt more ep do you think
kovat will impact conservative turnout
if anything it'll impact a Democratic
turnout because we see a very partisan
divide the right is widely ignoring the
warnings about kovat hanging out at
beaches ridiculing the entire thing so
if anything kovat is potentially more of
a liability for the eventual Democratic
nominee likely to be Joe Biden at this
point then for conservatives sadly sadly
Shane errs says lots of Arizona
independent voters that won't count
tonight Arizona has opened primaries but
calls this election presidential
preference not cool Farooq says NPR has
a better tracker thoughts on Iran
sanctions let me get the NPR primary
election results let's find that tracker
March 17 primaries there it is
and we will put that in you know I don't
know if this is actually better I guess
it's not bad it's it seems fine I don't
know that it's that much better but it
seems it seems reason if actually I
don't know that it's really better than
what we have from this seems kind of
bigger and and easier easier to read I
don't know I think both are fine I think
both are fine
we are waiting just eight minutes away
from Arizona numbers at this point in
time and a lot of information continuing
to come in
constantly Bob Adkins says do you like
Mata
Corona because old voters could Corona
cause old voters not to vote the corona
virus causing all the old voters not to
vote so far has not been an issue
I don't like Mata I've never liked it
coffee tea I'm all in Mata not not for
me not for me my friends unfortunately
let me say thank you to Ryan Recker Ryan
Recker is new member number 22 tonight
let's do a free item okay new member
number 25 tonight gets the item of your
choice from my website david pakman.com
slash gear I will personally send you
you can get a coffee mug you can get any
of the David Pakman show t-shirts any of
that stuff we are three members away
number 25 I will get you a free item
tonight
Sarah vessel's says does Bernie have a
path to a contested convention I don't
believe so in fact let me pull up the
538 let's see if I can find it here it
is so if we look at the 538 tracker they
believe that Biden having a majority
this is not a plurality right for a
plurality at this point it's actually
almost the same the this has has Biden
with greater than 99 percent odds of
getting a majority meaning no contested
convention
there's a 0.3 percent chance of a
contested convention and a 0.1 percent
chance of Bernie getting a majority
even when you go to plurality Bernie's
chance is still only 0.1 I tend to
believe the math and the data on on this
one at this point in time okay
take a look at Illinois 0-3 results
let's see if I can find that Democratic
primary results Illinois 0-3 let's take
a look here
Illinois 0-3 okay
let's pull that up now okay incumbent
dan Lipinski neela pissin key that looks
like it's a misspelling is trailing
behind chief opponent Marie Newman by
three points for the Democratic
nomination interesting this is a repeat
of 2018 but this time the tallies are
flipped Newman lost the 2018 primary by
2100 votes in an all nighter on the
Republican side votes are trickling in
Illinois Republican party endorsed Mike
fratello knee is leading Katherine
O'Shea and self-avowed neo-nazi art
Jones I've actually interviewed art
Jones let me let's just briefly see if I
can find that when did I interview art
Jones neo-nazi art Jones art Jones David
Pakman let's see if I can find that um
where is that interview I'm having
trouble finding it on my own channel art
Jones David Pakman yeah I interviewed
that guy and he was an absolute lunatic
Holocaust denier 3:54 that's not it Alex
Jones no that's not it man I'm having
trouble I'm gonna have to figure out how
to even find my own interview I
interviewed that guy and he's whacked
he's completely whacked interesting
interesting results so far from Illinois
0-3 as we are just moments potentially
moments from the last results of the
night okay let's see here where do we
stand on Oh
what's your opinion on market socialism
yeah so this is a good question from
William Franklin so as most of you know
I'm a Social Democrat I'm not a crime
not socialist and there are two models
which I think are to me much more
interesting than actually debating
socialism which I just it's like it's
not happening okay even if you want
socialism we we would need to get much
closer before it would even be a reality
market socialism and participatory
economics are both much more in line
with social democracy and they are sort
of modifications there they're still a
mixed economy and I I think a lot of
market socialism and participatory
economic systems are very very
interesting Bob
Adkins says wife says you are no
Argentinian if you don't like Mata well
believe it believe it
I am Argentinian and I don't like it
what else can I tell you okay
we we are potentially seconds from
starting to get information from Arizona
and based on the polling Arizona may be
closer than than all of the other states
so far or it may not and it may very
quickly be called we will just have to
wait and see at this point we don't know
if you're watching on YouTube let me
issue a very polite reminder make sure
to LIKE and subscribe liking and
subscribing the stream liking the stream
and subscribing off of it are both very
quick easy free ways to support the work
that we do and always very very much
appreciated okay let's go over and see
what is happening with Arizona moments
away from starting to get results and
let's see if we can even open it in its
own tab so that as soon as this happens
we will start to see results I think we
are very very close
Nick Newcomb says if the electoral
college is based on population of
location isn't the next logical step to
also make it based on race sex or income
is that good or bad I don't see at all
how that would be the logical next step
and that seems
that seems like a slippery slope that
seems like a significant slippery slope
to me and I don't know that I I don't
know that I really understand that that
that makes any sense to me okay
Arizona is officially closing as we hit
the stroke what does that even mean
I guess the the second hand we at the
stroke of 10:00 p.m. Eastern 7:00 p.m.
Pacific Arizona is closing and any
moment any moment we anticipate that
results are going to start showing up
and we may then know the full scope for
what is going on today we have we are
following all of the numbers as they
come in Florida of course almost
completely counted a brutal win brutal
win for Joe Biden Biden brutalizing
Bernie Sanders delegate tracker has a
282 delegate deficit currently for
Bernie Sanders Illinois also gone to
Biden and that lead is widening it was a
small as 17 it's now crept up to tweed
we are now at 10 p.m. and any second
we're going to start getting numbers out
of out of Arizona any predictions from
anybody what we're expecting from
Arizona anybody want to weigh in I know
it is potentially a fraught question but
curious what is on folks Minds we will
know very very soon that's for sure
polls have closed of course and ah there
is the tracker we are starting to get
data coming in let's see if we have
anything here any moment now we are
going to see those Arizona results
coming in some people predicting Tulsi
is going to win in Arizona some 5050
predictions 40 60 Biden surprised Jeb
Bush win that's a possibility that would
certainly surprise me that's for sure
let's see here also ran says stroke
comes from the stroke of a belt our
interesting Shannon Dennis what's the
difference between Social Democrat and
Democratic socialists
Social Democrats aren't socialists and
Democratic socialists are socialists so
Democratic socialists want to socialize
ownership of the means of production
businesses etc Social Democrats want
very well regulated capitalism where
taxes on the rich are used to fund
social programs reduced inequality more
the model of Denmark and Finland Norway
and Sweden not actual socialists
democratic socialists again
traditionally we can just say all these
definitions have changed and they're
meaningless but then it's like what is
what is language what does anything mean
traditionally democratic socialists are
actual socialists Mori asks how's Lewis
is he still in North Carolina no Lewis
was never living in North Carolina he
lived in Texas then he lived in Boston
and then he retreated to the hill towns
of Western Massachusetts where he still
is he's doing well saw him a couple
weeks ago we can't see each other
anymore because of the virus were self
isolating a Ryan C says this should have
been postponed
Biden wins period yeah I mean I think
Biden wins either way and that's part of
why I I anticipate that that Bernie
Sanders may drop out by tomorrow it's
weird when when the results get get kind
of skewed like that we don't have
anything yet it's every once in a while
this will happen where one can that its
results will span all the way across
seems like a CSS issue potentially for a
designer to take a look at Beezus see
Christ says there are only Bernie 2020
signs in Tucson Pima County we will see
how that reflects in the Arizona numbers
as they start to come in we have zero
point zero precincts reporting as of
right now zero point zero precincts
reporting as we continue to fight the
virus and wait for results to come in we
do have an offer on the table new we are
at 22 new members as you can see there
on my website join pakman.com new member
number 25 I will
you a free item from our online store
we'll send it anywhere in the world that
mail services deliver North Korea I
don't know if we can get it there I
don't think we have any viewers in North
Korea but number 25 so grab those
subscriptions at join pakman.com we will
also at that point burst through our
goal for the evening and somebody will
get a free item which is very exciting
William Franklin says is both parties
going to go back to centrism I don't
believe so no Pedro Augusto marques says
our Bernie or Buster's selfish kids in
cages I don't want to ascribe
selfishness to them we just have a
disagreement
I'm not blue no matter who I'm its Biden
versus Trump for me it's very specific
it's not this theoretical thing where I
have to say if I vote blue no matter who
then the Democratic Party doesn't have
to do anything for me as a progressive
because they just know I'm gonna vote no
matter what it's not blue no matter who
it's I prefer buy it into Trump so I'm
going to vote for Biden because I don't
want Trump getting another four years
it's that simple
it's that simple for me Michael Gabriel
Ibrahim says how can Biden pull Bernie
supporters for the general it's gonna be
a fight he's going to need a strategy
and I don't know what the answer is I
don't know how he does it but if he
doesn't he won't win if Biden can't get
a sizable portion of Bernie supporters
to come over to him Trump will get
reelected it's as simple as that so he's
going to have to figure it out somehow
what one way or the other
and if he doesn't then we're going to
get another four years of Trump
quite simply quite frankly that's the
way that that it is going to be we are
still waiting on early numbers from
Arizona we don't know exactly why they
have not come in yet we were thinking
that at the top of the hour they would
start coming in presumably they are
being communicated and called in now and
any moment any moment we should start
hearing from them if you voted so far in
the primaries doesn't have to be today
but if you voted at all
I would love for you to let me know be a
super chat what state you voted in and
for whom you voted now I keep ice e
people saying you're not going to get
them are people talking about the
Arizona results is there something I
missed about why we are unlikely to get
Arizona results tonight that I just am
unaware of I was under the impression we
were going to get Arizona results
tonight poll times were extended until
9:00 Eastern in Arizona well it's 10:00
Eastern now so that doesn't really make
sense
Arizona is slow they will come out no
results here for another hour
no Arizona results for another hour some
people are saying Arizona 11 p.m.
I don't let's let's do a Twitter search
about that I I hadn't heard anything
about that let's see
Arizona results see what we've got
latest um we should know results by 8
p.m. 8 p.m. their time are they two or
three hours behind right now because
that varies current time in Arizona it
is currently seven so we are according
to that we are 53 minutes away
everybody's talking about 8 p.m. Arizona
time so that is going to be a little
okay so we're gonna have to wait a
little longer on that interesting I did
not I did not realize that I guess it
might be because of that because of that
extension okay Maury asks what's your
style of playing basketball Steve Nash
yes very much so very much so I'm I'm a
Steve Nash sort of a sort of player for
sure the tone guy or that one guy one
trillion dollar stimulus but Medicare
for all is unaffordable yeah I had a
tweet about that earlier actually let me
see exactly how I phrased it see if it
tickles your fancy as something that you
may want to retweet potentially someday
the way I said it was incredible how
quickly stuff that normally we can't
afford has become we can't afford not to
to be clear this is good and correct but
we should remember this
once things settle out and they resume
the same talking points and of course a
bunch of people were reacting with stuff
like this actually this person was
saying this is what the argument will be
and then people made it emergency
funding is different than perpetual
borrowing temporary relief is different
than long-term policy apples and oranges
but of course the point is a lot of
these things if we had them all the time
would prevent this degree of crisis
right now so let me give you an example
if we had paid sick leave and paid time
off for restaurant workers all the time
as a thing we wouldn't now be panicking
saying oh crap
tipped employees are gonna make zero we
have no paid vacation we have no
anything for them now we have to
scramble and throw money at the problem
so I actually disagree that it's apples
and oranges it's a question of do we do
it in an organized way when we're not in
a crisis and prevent a problem or do we
now just start throwing money at
different things all over the place
that's fundamentally the difference here
okay
why hasn't Obama endorsed the Biden
would it help Obama is staying out of
this because I believe he knows that if
he gets involved and the person he
endorses doesn't win it gets ugly in the
general and he wants to have more
credibility in the general so I
understand why he's doing it Biden's
gonna easily win anyway so I don't think
it's gonna be a problem
David Adams says voted in Washington for
Bernie Michael Gabriel Ibrahim says
should Biden offer Bernie a cabinet spot
that's for Biden to figure out it's too
early for me to think about that Bosko
sends a super chat Vasile vonda says
will Biden actively pursue Medicare for
all no he doesn't even support it no no
he's not gonna he's not gonna do that
Susan Dover Latham has grabbed a beta
subscription on YouTube you know I've
been jokingly saying that I'm a data
male making fun of Jesse Lee Peterson's
beta mail thing and somebody suggested
we should get a t-shirt and sell it on
the website
I would love to do that we I will make
that happen if somebody can design it I
just have no skills to design such a
t-shirt let me say thank you to pakil
Evera who has subscribed with twitch
Prime at twitch.tv slash David Pakman
thanks very much
appreciate that let me say thank you to
Alex Civic who is new member number 23
tonight
thanks Alex we are just two members away
from our goal and new member number 25
as I said gets a free item from my um
from the David Pakman show online store
okay so we are waiting on results from
Arizona we are oh I think I had some a
couple videos I wanted to go over with
you guys let me pull those up just while
we are talking here I find the proper
notes okay where is that uh I had a
bunch of stuff I wanted to go over with
you guys today
coronavirus test we talked about oh yeah
check this out you know whenever there
are vulnerable people
grifters come out of the woodwork and
this is there's no shortage of that
right now
check out this pastor who will uh oh
woops nope that's the right that's not
the right thing that's Trump saying it's
a National Day of Prayer that's not the
right thing this is the right video this
is Kenneth Copeland apparently claiming
to cure corona virus through the
television check out how irresponsible
decisions yes how they move thank you
Jesus thank you Lord Jesus
he received your hailing yes now say it
I take it I have it I have it's mine
it's mine I thank you and praise you for
it yes and I forgive if I have aught
against any and I praise you that I'm
well and whole can you imagine
according to the Word of God his hands
all wet I'm healed yes and I consider
not my own body
I consider not symptoms in my body I
considered a symptom but only that which
God has published what the word has said
by His stripes I was healed and by His
stripes I am healed now is this mental
illness a grift or both I'm not the sick
trying to get healed
I'm the heel and the devil's trying to
give me the flu train or whatever else
kind of thing he's trying yeah special
look at that at the bottom it says
special report standing against
coronavirus healed and well yes and a
sweet name in Jesus Jesus that guy's
worth seven hundred and sixty million
dollars
here's another grifter who says that he
will cure you if you drink silver this
guy has actually done prison time for
fraud he's back out now telling you to
drink silver he was this product yeah I
believe yes listen to that again God
gave us this product yeah I believe why
wouldn't God just not give us
coronavirus right like isn't it if
you're God and you're busy
you're dealing with you know billions of
planets and stars and solar systems why
give earth coronavirus and then give
earth earth silver to drink right why
not just prevent coronavirus to begin
with yes and we have it at our home
while opening cases we use it all the
time I have this and I mean I don't
think I'd have made it without silver
yep we would have lost them without it
it for my throat in all that absolutely
as I've had this and this is amazing
why would you recommend is a doctor
people to have silver in there by the
way doctor she's a naturopath okay and
again yeah this this is sort of like if
you have a dog
they're a philosophy and you ask them
about medication and refer to them only
as doctor it's dishonest house for you
never want to be without silver that's
so many reasons never never you know
this is a staple
yes state this is a staple for your
family yeah and we can talk more about
it maybe we have more time yeah I got
time all I can say is that it has been
proven by the government which
government she doesn't say that it has
the ability to kill every pathogen it
has ever been tested on including SARS
and HIV right right what what is that
this is it's very bad this is very very
bad folks and unfortunately there is a
lot of grift going on and then also
apparently oh I guess Alex Jones is
selling something similar as well let me
find that Alex Jones selling coronavirus
toothpaste oh that's interesting let me
see if I can find that Alex Jones
toothpaste let's see if we have that
this is just Alex Jones on the street I
would love a video I'm just gonna tell
you that purchase your daily life and
your gums and your teeth and for regular
viruses and bacteria the patented nano
silver we have the Pentagon has come out
and documented and homeland security and
said this stuff kills the whole SARS
coronal at point-blank range well of
course it does it kills every virus oh
boy yeah so that's very very very very
dangerous let's see if Media Matters has
any more extensive video on this let's
go right back with your calls I promise
oh we've got buffering 8 7 7 7 8 9 to 5
3 not on this Tuesday global
transmission I'm not gonna belabor this
I'm just gonna tell you that for just
your daily life and your gums and your
teeth and for regular virus
bacteria a lot of buffering on the Media
Matters site I'm not loving it the
patented nano silver we have the
Pentagon has come out and documented and
homeland security and said this stuff
kills the whole SARS corona family at
point-blank range well of course it does
it kills every virus right uh-huh
but it's deafening they found that and
then this is this is 13 years ago and
the Pentagon uses the product we have
and the product we have and private
label says like when he says that it
does he mean that the people who work at
the Pentagon brushed their teeth with
his silver toothpaste is about to be in
Walmart coming up they just ordered a
massive crap ton of that not the one
they have this even better one that we
have so I'm just saying we're always
cutting edge think to God I just go with
the research go with the spirit we
always have it then the Nano the silver
tooth paste in the super blue with the
tea tree and the iodine that's the super
blue is amazing then we have the
whitening toothpaste that has the vinyl
silver and a lot more as well those are
both excellent item for short our comics
will discount despite all the hell
breaking loose
we have storable food in stock but we
have to package it and it's six to eight
weeks behind shipping it out to you
other people allowed to you the big old
Pinocchio noses we're not that's what's
going on you want storable food you
wanna get delivered this thing of it is
super bad dekes in about 12 weeks in the
u.s. the models show so you'll get your
food in for store.com and it's high
quality it's very low price they haven't
raised prices yet but i'm told it's next
week 24 store.com and bodies ultimate
for me oh my god in with a Led Zeppelin
and everything so anyway
grifters are grifting folks and you've
got to be very very very very careful
PBS seems to have ended their entire
thing they're not even going live
anymore now we're down to just the ABC
stream we're like the last people left
here ladies and gentlemen okay let's get
to things that I've missed
Maddy ice has subscribed with twitch
prime Justin sing gree is new member
number 24 tonight and Erin Larian is new
member number 25 tonight Erin thank you
as new member number 25 you get a free
item from the David Pakman show online
store pick something
now let me know the color the size email
in using the website contact form at
david pakman.com we will get it out to
you very very much appreciate it
okay super chats coming in let's see
here what is your favorite artist or
band oh they're so I couldn't pot that's
like saying what's my favorite book I
couldn't possibly narrow it down
Sharleen Hughes has grabbed the
membership Susan Dover Latham is a
member Jennifer Silva ji has grabbed a
youtube membership Charlie says David
does your hair look that good first
thing in the morning no also is that
when 25th membership spots still
available no it's just been given away
Monica says Biden needs a OC is VP to
get the progressive vote interesting I
don't think it's gonna happen
Martellus says cool Michael Norman says
David this isn't grifting some extreme
Christians practice this my mother was
just like this and passed away from
cancer not believing she had cancer very
unfortunate that is tragic I'm so sorry
to hear that that is tragic Sheila Joe
Kornblum says Missouri AG just sued Jim
Baker for kovat cure claim beautiful
clever to swear says please do your best
Alex Jones impression I don't know if I
could it's like silver toothpaste
something like that right I can't really
get his uh like you know part of it is
just you know he's bonkers and I can't
transmit that the Beckman Nader says how
the Heller televangelist still around in
2020 I don't know but some of them have
private planes which is crazy Ben Taylor
says hey D hope you're well do you think
it's funny how people are so fascinated
by personal life backs of yours I guess
it's cuz you're such a celebrity now
it's very cute when we think you're
embarrassed huh I don't even know what
Ben's referring to Aaron Larian says
thanks so much you pronounced my name
perfectly thank you very much very very
nice I love it
very much appreciate that support okay
let's see if we have any updated
information we still do not and Arizona
numbers
likely will not come in probably not
until the until the top of the hour we
have Illinois results where Joe Biden
has won by 22 as of now we have Florida
results where Joe Biden has won by 39 as
of now and the delegate count continues
to be a 282 delegate lead for Joe Biden
remember you guys voted by a 63 237
margin that if Bernie is down by 250
tonight he should suspend his campaign
and he is right in that range as of
right now so that is certainly something
that he will have to contend with for
sure clever to swear says Alex Jones
impression not bad now do Trump oh I
can't do Trump I don't know how to do
that I I just don't know I don't really
do impressions it's not really my thing
sadly but maybe some day would be
something something to consider
oh this is I think they're doing all of
the Trump coronavirus exposure
they've done a fantastic job
our relationship has never been closer
great to have it next community
captured everybody's head
yeah again I don't know that I believe
Donald Trump when he says that that he
was tested because his explanation
during the press conference yesterday
was just very very weird let me see if I
can find the video for you here yeah
here it is
check this out this is Trump talking
about being Ted like the timeline
doesn't make sense just nothing about it
makes sense take a look Friday night the
White House doctor's office put out a
statement around midnight Friday saying
that no test was indicated so when
exactly was your test administered well
I had my test I was late Friday night
and the reason I did it was because the
I had no symptoms whatsoever so the
doctor said you have no symptoms so we
don't see any reason but when I did the
press conference on Friday everybody was
going crazy did you do the test did you
do the test so very late on Friday night
I did the test and he may have put out
or the doctor may have put out something
at it I don't know what time the letter
went out maybe it was put up by somebody
else but the results came back I believe
the following day and so it's already
all weird cuz it's like at 3:30 on
Friday he said he doesn't need a test
Friday night he says the White House
doctor said he doesn't need a test and
Friday night he took a test the tests
are taking 48 to 72 hours to come back
somehow within under 24 hours he already
had the results it's all weird
we tested negative well I told them that
and I went totally by what they said the
doctors more than one they said not to
get in and you got any of the symptoms
they checked what you're supposed to
check and that I didn't have symptoms if
you keep an eye on dr. Burks this face
she seems to be sort of communicating
something with her expression I did it I
did a test late on Friday night and it
came back probably 24 hours later or
something they sent it to the labs came
back
nah not something I want to do every day
I can tell you that it's you know it's a
little bit of a it's a little bit of
good doctors in the White House but it's
a test it's a test it's a medical test
I think pleasant to bed it's a medical
attach to what else can you say so
anyway I don't know that he I don't know
that Donald Trump actually had the test
after after seeing all of that it's it's
just it's just not clear to me that he
actually had the test and if you know I
don't know it seems like he was being
careful not to say anything that would
make it clear he didn't have it like he
said you know I don't like getting blood
drawn and someone would have said well
mr. president it's not a test where you
get blood drawn he seemed to be very
careful about not giving any detail in
order to make it clear that he doesn't
know what the hell he's talking about
okay Hamiltonian says go to Jones's
website he's not even selling the food
anymore he ran out that is crazy that
people are actually buying Alex Jones's
a big food storage Shawna angles Minh
has also subscribed on YouTube I'm
getting notifications that the Arizona
results may even be further delayed and
since it seems as though it will be
inconsequential and we have a very long
day tomorrow and the stream is slowing
down I think we're actually going to end
our coverage at this time a lot has gone
on lately what would the virus and we
will pick up our coverage and results
tomorrow it probably is time for Bernie
to start wrapping the campaign based on
the numbers will have Arizona results
tomorrow for you and then much much more